How do I help support
these young women?
This is exactly what
I had always hoped
is that we'd find a way that
we could normalize bikes
so that we could get girls
bikes to get to schools.
( applause )
Hi, everyone. Thanks
so much for coming out.
I am truly, truly
honored to be here
at National Geographic
headquarters.
So, let's be clear.
I did not go
to Afghanistan
intending to ride
a mountain bike.
I don't think anyone goes to
an active war zone and thinks,
"if only I had brought my
lycra and my single-speed."
You know, what was I thinking.
No, I started in Afghanistan,
my first visit in 2008
to work with women and girls.
Afghanistan is repeatedly
ranked by numerous indexes
as the worst place in the
world to be a woman.
And yet, as a country where I
have focused my attention
for the last seven
to eight years
because I believe that women
and girls are the future.
Not just in Afghanistan,
but around the world.
Afghanistan is a country
that begs to be explored.
It's insanely beautiful.
And I'm sure there may
be one of two of you
that have been able to see the
country in the 60s and 70s
when it was part of
the tourist trail.
It was literally part
of the hippie trail.
It had great marijuana, and
people were traveling through
to experience this in
the 1960s and 1970s.
It has a history
with the Silk Road.
There's a lot of sports
in Afghanistan now
that are open to
women and girls.
Bikes are the anomaly.
Cycling is a sport that is
inherently taboo for
women and girls.
This is a shot from 2008.
And this while she
is in a burkha
you have women in
headscarves as well
riding side saddle, riding
horses side saddle.
Riding motorcycles side saddle.
Regardless of their dress
they are not allowed
to straddle a bike seat,
motorcycle seat, or a horse.
It is considered
culturally obscene.
And no good girl would do this.
As a matter of...
I live in Colorado
and point of fact
I'm a mountain biker.
It is the sport I
have come to love.
It is the sport that keeps
me sane and grounded.
And I started to explore
when I was in Afghanistan
this concept that was presented
to me on my very first visit
of being a hybrid gender.
In Afghanistan, as a foreign
woman, I obviously do not blend.
I stand out and what I found
was rather than a hindrance
that was actually one
of my greatest assets.
Because I wanted to work
with women and girls
but in Afghanistan the men
are the gate keepers.
And what I found was that I was
considered an honorary man.
They knew I was a woman, but yet
they treated me like a man.
They conversed with
me like a man.
They invited me to
dinner like a man.
So, over the next
four-five years
I started pushing on
those gender barriers
and enjoying the interactions
that I had with Afghan men.
Laughing and joking with them.
Fishing with them in
the Panjshir River.
They've allowed me
to ride horses.
This is a Buzkashi horse.
If a woman rides a horse,
the idea is that that Buzkashi
horse will never compete again.
So, it was a huge honor to
be able to ride this horse
that later competed in that
game and did well.
And it was only really
a matter of time
before I would decide to bring
my bike to Afghanistan.
And on my third visit in 2009,
I brought over my
single-speed 29er.
And experimented in
the Panjshir Valley.
I'd been working there,
asking people if they thought
it would be okay
if I rode a bike
I mean, would that offend them,
and tried to source that out.
Everyone was
supportive of the idea.
And I went in an
area where I knew
that it was clear
of land mines,
that I knew was...
relatively safe and
where the locals knew me.
And I started doing little rides
just to experiment what would
happen if a girl rode a bike.
Afghanistan is one of the
only countries in the world
where girls and women are
not allowed to ride.
It's not illegal like
it was in Saudi Arabia.
It's simply not allowed.
The men that I encounter
are so flabbergasted
and so overwhelmed
with curiosity
that the normal barriers that
we have are just blown away.
So, security guards,
Afghan National Police,
the Army, they've
all ridden my bike.
I may have ridden
theirs if they had one.
And what I realized was
that in that sharing,
that I could maybe
finagle a back door.
And in one case in point
it was Darul Aman Palace.
Darul Aman Palace was the
king's palace in Kabul.
It was... it became ground
zero during the Civil War
before Taliban times for
a lot of different base camps
for Mujahedin fighters, there's
bullet holes all throughout
Islamic graffiti inside.
I wanted to visit inside and
see what the inside had
looked like, desperately.
And I kept going
back every visit.
I've been there 19 times now,
and I, every single time
was like "I'm going to get in.
It's going to be a different
day, a different guard
charm him, he's going
to let me in."
And, no, never.
So, I had my bike one day
and went for a bike
ride with a friend
up to, and just did hot laps
around Darul Aman Palace.
We were just riding around...
the roads.
And this man comes up.
Turns out...
through the access of
I'm on a bike, you're on a
bike, let's talk bikes.
He's the gardener.
He's been the gardener since
he was nine years old.
He says that he's 88.
But in Afghanistan
very few people
know what their
real age is.
But he says he's 88,
that he's been the gardener
since he was a young boy.
So, he's seen everything.
He's like
little nugget of history
embodied in an amazing man
who immediately said,
"well, why are you here?"
I said, "well, I just...
I'm fascinated by the
history of this place.
I've always wanted
to go inside."
And he walks over, he's like,
"go give him your bike."
And walk, and not give it
to him, give it to him.
Like, let's give it for a ride.
So, I asked the security guards
if he wants to ride my bike.
They come out, discover
the joys of disc brakes.
And he face plants.
( audience laughter )
And I think we've
ruined any chance
that I've ever had
to get in this place.
And he dusts himself off, and
shakes, kind of embarrassed.
But he's blood-free,
thank goodness.
And all of them take, there's
three security guards,
they're Afghan National
Police, guarding this place.
They open the gate of
barbed wire, let me in,
not just me, myself, but
me, myself, and my bike.
And allow me and my
bike to go inside
and ride up and down the halls
and experience what was once
one the most
incredibly beautiful
places in Afghanistan.
The King's Palace.
But it was one of those
experiences where you realize
that again, it's access,
it's a human connection.